Okay.
Well,
this week and next week I'm going to concentrate on settings,
the contexts,
um,
introducing you to the contours of a UN unfamiliar society.
And today I'll start with the social order.
How people perceive their social world as a whole in the 16th century.
Okay.
Well,
500 years ago in the fall of the,
uh,
1,509,
a man named Edmond Dudley lay imprisoned in the tower of London,
the great royal fortress,
which dominated decent parts of London as it still does.
He was there on trumped up charges of treason.
A Dudley was a lawyer.
He had assisted King Henry the seventh in some very unpopular policies.
And in 1,509,
the old king died,
the new King Henry the eighth came to the throne,
h on the 18 and one,
some quick popularity by throwing admin Dudley to the wolves.
But as he lay in prison awaiting execution,
Dudley made his peace with man and God by writing a book,
which he called the tree of Commonwealth.
It didn't save him and he probably never expected that it would,
but it's survived and it remains a classic statement of 16th century social
values and it can serve to introduce some of the keywords of 16th century
society
in the tree of Commonwealth.
Dudley attempted as a loyal subject to describe what he saw as the ideal
conditions for the prospering of the kingdom under its new King Henry the
eighth,
the word that he used it as title Commonwealth was a real key word of 16th
century political discourse.
It meant the body politic,
the whole of the realm.
It also meant the common good,
the common interests,
the public welfare of society.
In discussing it,
um,
Dudley,
in his book I took the form of an elaborate allegory.
He imagined the Commonwealth as a great tree.
There were four routes of Commonwealth,
love of God,
justice,
trust and Concord.
And there were four fruits of Commonwealth tranquility.
Good example,
worldly prosperity and the honor of God.
Well,
the fruits of Commonwealth,
this happy outcome of harmonious Commonwealth involved the reconciling under the
guiding hand of the king,
of the interests of all the principles,
social groups,
so that conflict would be avoided and everyone would be welded into a harmonious
Commonwealth.
So in describing the Commonwealth,
Dudley describe the various components,
social groups,
and he divided the subjects of the realm,
uh,
in a way that was very conventional into what he called three estates or orders,
three estates,
each of which had its role and each of which had its duties.
First of all came the clergy.
Their role was to pray for the good of the whole,
uh,
to sustain Christian values by their pastoral ministry and to avoid the
temptations of worldliness or lusts of the flesh.
All of this was explained.
Then he turned to the second estate,
what he called the chivalry,
chivalry with a late elite ranging in status from Duke's at the top down to mere
nights,
esquires and gentlemen,
all of these people were considered to be of gentle blood.
Their duty was to defend the realm in time of war and to governor justly in time
of peace under the king.
They should avoid the abuse of their power as governors or as landlords.
They should protect and relieve the poor and the weak and serve the king well.
Thirdly,
there were those that Dudley called the commonalty of the realm,
the commonalty,
and basically that was all the rest,
the common people from the peasantry of the countryside to the great merchants
of the cities,
all those who are not of gentle blood.
Their duty was to work,
to get in living that was appropriate for their place in society to keep their
families and to support all the rest.
They were advised by Dudley to avoid covetousness or greed,
to avoid idleness and to avoid what he called presumption above the degree.
They should keep their place.
They should also avoid grunting and murmuring against the fact that they were
born as he put it to live in labor and pain and for the most part of their time
in the sweat of their face.
This is an excellent advice for students.
I I repeat that.
Avoid grudging and murmuring.
Accept that you're here to live in labor and pain and the most part of your time
in the sweat of your face.
Okay,
well,
all of this is a perfectly conventional account of the structures and purposes
of the social order in the 16th century.
It's partly descriptive of the major component groups of society.
It's partly obviously prescriptive.
It's prescribing how they should live and in doing so,
it embodies the central ideals of the social morality of the time as it was
conceived by people like Dudley harmony duty order.
Now,
clearly this idea was communitarian w was very preoccupied with the
Commonwealth.
That's an association of interdependent parts,
a community,
but equally clearly it was not egalitarian.
The component groups might be interdependent,
but they were emphatically not equal.
Each group was expected to contribute in its degree as Dudley put it in its
degree according to its place,
and each could share in the benefits of the Commonwealth after it's degree in
accordance with its place.
Now by degree,
he meant of course the different gradations of wealth and status inside each of
the three estates.
That's hierarchical ranking was fundamental to 16th century notions of the
social order and people were never allowed to forget it.
Okay,
well let's leave Edmund Dudley meditating in his cell in the tower and imagine
ourselves instead in one of England's 9,000 parish churches a few decades later.
So Sunday morning,
the bells are tolling to call people to church.
The church wardens,
kind of like the teaching fellows of the 16th century parish.
The church wardens are petroleum.
The isles getting people sat in their proper place,
gentry up at the front,
the lowly at the back,
and they're chasing up the dogs because people brought their dogs to church in
those days and settling everyone down.
And once a year the grave gray beard administer of the parish would come into
the pulpit and read out from the book of homilies.
Book of harmonies were official sermons which were published by the Church of
England and what we read out periodically in the course of the year
he began,
thus all mighty God hath created and appointed all things in heaven,
earth and waters in a most excellent and perfect order in heaven.
He has appointed distinct orders and estates of archangels and angels in Earth.
He has assigned kings,
princes with governors under them all in good and necessary order.
Every degree of people in their vocation,
their calling and their office have appointed to them their duty and order.
Some are in high degree,
some in low,
some kings and princes,
some inferiors and subjects,
priests and laymen,
masters and servants,
fathers and children,
husbands and wives,
rich and poor
and where there is no right order there ane oth all abuse,
carnal liberty,
enormity,
sin and Babylon.
Nickel confusion.
Well that's the opening paragraph of the homily on obedience.
The homily on obedience published for the first time in the 1540s and another
niche statement of to the perceptions of the social order and his emphasis on
hierarchy and degree audit.
The word echoing through that opening paragraph.
Well put Dudley and the homily on obedience together.
And you've got a world which certainly had certain communitarian ideals,
the Commonwealth,
but one in which it was also assumed that those ideals were best served by
maintaining a sort of graduated ladder of authority and subordination within
each one of the degrees of society.
And indeed the three degrees as Dudley described them can be shuffled together
into a single rank order of precedence as they were when people went on
processions.
Uh,
for example,
on the back of your handout,
you'll find a chart laying out as one hierarchy.
That classical social hierarchy,
which you've already read about.
I hope,
uh,
in the chapter set from English society.
Okay,
well if you think back to what I've said so far,
it's clear that within all of this they were making four kinds of distinctions
between people.
There were distinctions of function,
your role in the Commonwealth,
there were distinctions of rank and have status.
They were distinctions of course in gender.
And there were distinctions of age,
parents and children.
And many of these distinctions tended to overlap.
So I want now to look at them a little more closely,
starting by looking at rank and status,
the hierarchy that they emphasized so much.
And here I'll skip along quite smartly.
You've had a chance to read about this already to some degree,
but I just reinforced some of the main points.
Okay,
well,
at the top of the social hierarchy,
obviously enough stood the king and his immediate family.
The king was not only the greatest of the English nobility,
which he was and the greatest single landowner in the kingdom,
which he also was,
but he was also something special.
The king was the anointed of God as they put it,
ritually anointed with sacred oil at the time of the coronation,
the fount of all secular authority in the realm but also considered to be ruling
by the special grace of God.
Beneath the crown came Dudley chivalry and that was itself internally
differentiated into on the one hand and your hand out will help with this.
On the one hand,
the peerage and on the other hand,
the Gentry,
the peerage where the greater nobility,
they were the nobles who are distinguished by having inheritable titles which
could be passed on to their sons.
Duke's Oh,
those mock courses,
icons,
Barron's lords.
They also had a favorable position before the law.
They could only be tried by their peers,
usually in the House of Lords.
When parliament sat,
they had the right to sit in parliament by virtue of their birth and social
position.
Alongside those great lane nobles,
one can also place some of the great churchmen,
the bishops,
the abbots of great monasteries.
They also sat in parliament in the House of Lords because they were the lords of
the church.
But an important distinction of course was that their positions were not
inheritable.
They were appointed and the early 16th century appointed by the pope,
though usually on the advice and recommendation of the king,
so we've looked at the peerage,
the greater nobility.
Then there was the lesson ability,
which contemporaries referred to usually as the gentry.
They were themselves internally differentiated into nights.
Esquires and Mir gentleman nights
were created by the monarch for service,
for service in war usually or in government as indeed they still are high
ranking civil servants in Britain and military officers very often get a
knighthood at the end of their active careers.
Though the notion of service has broadened somewhat nowadays to include other
roles in society.
So we have a Syrian Mckellen,
uh,
also known as Gandalf.
Um,
we have support and Mccartney of course,
and we even have a sub Mick Jagger,
which proves that he was just a nice boy really all along.
Um,
so the,
the apartment of nights,
the dubbing of nights by the Mana continues of course in the 16th century,
they were usually selected to be made nights for amongst the leading families of
each of the 40 counties of the kingdom.
And the title could not be inherited.
You had to be made at night again in each new generation below them where the
lesser gentry of Esquires and Meir Gentlemen,
they had no title except the right to be called Mister.
Only a gentlemen could be called Mr. And they had the right also to bear a coat
of arms.
Collectively the nobility,
both the peerage and the church leaders and the gentry were the principal
landowners of England and Wales,
uh,
in the county of North Yorkshire,
for example.
It's up here in the north of England.
In the early 16th century,
a study has been done,
which shows that the nobility,
the peerage,
owned 27% of the land.
The gentry owned 46% and nearly all of the rest belong to the church.
Land was not only a source of income,
the rent,
which were paid to the great landowners,
but it was also a source of power over tenants.
It was a source of Lordship as they put it in this period.
Lordship over men,
some gentlemen that owned only a single smaller state.
Some had many,
and by the time you get to the peerage,
some of them had vast territories.
The Earl of Shrosbree,
whom land counter again at various times owned a great deal of land in the
center of England and the counties of Nottingham.
Sure Darbyshire and Shropshire.
And he was described at the time as being like a prince in four counties in the
heart of England.
He was the biggest landowner by far in that whole region.
So in any one county,
those who possess the land constituted it's natural governing class,
and some of them had been in that position for generations,
but whatever pride they took in their rank and their ancestry,
they knew very well that it was based ultimately upon the land that they
possessed upon their land at wealth.
One gentleman said,
John Logar advised his sons as follows,
without wealth,
the support and upholder of gentry and worldly reputation,
then nobility and gentility is but vain and contemptible title in England and
always has been preserve your estate if you will preserve your gentility and
nobility of blood,
which is nothing else but a descent of riches.
Got a frank recognition of the realities of the social structure.
Okay,
so no woman and gentlemen possessed most landed property,
but of course they were only a tiny proportion of the population.
Probably something like 2%.
The other 98% where the commonalty and of these,
the majority lived in the countryside,
England in the 1520s,
the earliest period for which we can make really good population estimates had
about 2.4 million people and not more than 10% of them lived in towns.
Indeed,
uh,
only 5% of them lived in towns that were bigger than 5,000 inhabitants.
5,000 inhabitants was considered a good big town.
In the 16th Century,
uh,
Wales had a population of only about a quarter of a million and even fewer lived
in towns.
It's a mountainous region,
very few urban settlements except around the coast.
So we're dealing with an overwhelmingly rural society.
But the commonality we're far from being just an undifferentiated massive
peasants in rural society beneath the landowning gentleman who drew their income
from rents,
people will normally divided into four subordinate groups.
There were Yeoman,
there were husbandman,
they were craftsmen and tradesmen,
and there were cottages and laborers.
You'll find definitions of these different groups on your handout.
Yoh men are sometimes defined as being owner occupiers who possessed freehold
land.
And there's sometimes where,
but in fact most of them were tenant farmers.
The crucial thing about Yeoman is that they were substantial tenant farmers.
People who employ labor,
people who could produce them,
a substantial marketable surplus which they could sell to the towns.
These were the people who were sometimes described as the better sort of people
in their villages or the teeth inhabitants
beneath them where husbandman small family farmers generally with holdings of
under 30 acres or so enough to support their families and to produce a modest
surplus to sell,
but relying for the most part on their direct family labor.
Then there were village craftsmen and tradesmen.
Some of them might be people of Substance Millers and blacksmiths.
We're able to make a good living.
For example,
others were usually poor tailors or ale.
Housekeepers who brewed ale were generally relatively poor.
Most craftsmen felt somewhere between the two and most of them also farmed as
well as performing the duties of their craft.
And finally there were the cottages and laborers.
They sometimes held a few acres of land which they rented from a local landlord
or from a local farmer.
Some of them might have a trade from time to time,
but most of them relied upon wages for at least a significant part of their
income working as farm laborers on the holdings of bigger tenants.
Well,
one can generalize in that kind of way,
but the proportions of the rural population that fell into these different
groups varied enormously from place to place.
What you can say in general is that rural society was highly differentiated.
A large minority of big yeoman farmers,
a broad middle band of people who could get a secure living as a craftsman or as
husbandman and another large minority,
probably about a quarter in the early 16th century who put together a rather
bare hand to mouth to mouth living as cottages and laborers,
but most people still had access to the land one way or another.
Even cottages and laborers generally had a small holding and they would have the
right to graze their animals on the Commons of their village rights of pasture
complete dependence upon wage labor was still exceptional in the countryside and
I emphasize that because that's something that was going to change as we will
see in the course of the 16th century.
What about the towns then
towns,
people?
As I've said,
we're very much a minority,
but there were a very significant minority.
The town's ranged from tiny market towns which came alive on market day two what
were considered the great cities with populations of above 5,000
and the one truly significant city,
the city of London down here in the southeast with the population in the early
16th century,
which had already reached about 55,000 so London was a significant city by the
standards of the day.
I look at the distribution of towns in another lecture,
but the thing to stress today is that even small towns had a much more very
gated occupational and social structure.
Then did country villages,
they contain merchants,
they contained manufacturers.
They contained the small number of highly prestigious professional people,
lawyers,
physicians.
They contain more clergy than country villages,
and they contained also large numbers of unskilled laborers.
So much for the range of occupations.
But within that range,
they were considerable differentials of wealth and status at the top.
The great merchants of the cities could be men of prodigious wealth who were
generally also the rulers of their towns.
To give you just one example,
uh,
a man named Robert Janice,
spelled j,
he was a,
a grocer and he was the mayor of the city of knowledge here in east Anglian
region in the early 16th century.
In 15,
23 attacks was levied a for which the return survive.
And so we know that Robert Genesis personal tax return was bigger than the
entire city of Rochester,
which was the biggest city down here in Kent.
He was a plutocrat and there were men of such prodigious wealth in all of
England's major cities,
but it's the urban elites where the average master craftsman of the towns,
those who provided
clothing,
leather goods,
metal wares and so forth from their own workshops.
The principle of distinction amongst these people was between those who were
independent mastercraftsman with their own workshop and those who are known as
journeymen,
people who work for wages by the day,
skilled workers serving as employees of the master craftsman
among the master craftsman.
Most of them worked entirely on their own account producing and retailing their
goods,
but there were also those in some cities who had become virtually employees of
large scale merchant capitalists who gave them raw materials to work on,
collected the finished products and marketed the goods.
This was known as the putting out system.
You put out work to skilled workers and you collect the goods and market them,
and I mentioned it specifically because it was the form of organization in
England's most important single industry,
the cloth industry,
the manufacturer of woolen cloth,
most of which was exported to Europe and which was very prominent in certain
regions.
Norritch was a great cloth city,
so were many of the other towns of East Anglia,
southern England and parts of the West country.
Okay.
We've looked at at some of the major distinctions of wealth and status,
rank and degree.
Let's turn to two other categories that contemporaries tended to stress gender
and age
for the most part.
So far in talking about wealth and status and rank,
I've been talking about adult men
and to do that is an accurate reflection of the attitudes of the time,
the attitudes which they held towards the position of women and of the young
women and young people took their place in the social order from either their
husbands or their fathers or their masters.
And to that extent it's been said,
their social identities were subsumed,
absorbed into the social identities of the adult male heads of the households
within which they lived.
When people talked about the social order as a whole,
women and children became almost invisible.
They were just subsumed into the identities of adult male householders.
Nevertheless,
contemporary moralists did have very clear views about the place of women and
children and the young in general and in both cases that place was a subordinate
one.
Now of course women and some of the young word distinguished by social rank just
as adult men were.
Some women in particular might hold positions of great status and power by
virtue of their birth and their inheritance and we'll meet quite a few of them
in the course of the 16th century.
But nonetheless,
although women were obviously distinguished by their rank,
they were also collectively distinguished by gender.
The social roles deemed proper for the different sexes and such.
Distinctions were also fundamental to the structure of the social order as the
homily on obedience makes clear
in general,
women's place was seen as that of being dutiful adjunct to men as daughters,
as wives,
as mothers or as sisters.
They had little recognized role outside the household and few opportunities to
pursue an independent career.
At least in theory it was so
that's subordination was justified by the authority of scripture.
Saint Paul was constantly quoted on that point and it was also justified in
English law,
especially the law of property.
According to English common law property was vested in Male household heads.
An unmarried woman who was described in law it using the Norman French that they
used in the law courts who was described in law as a thin sole.
You'll find the term on your handout.
And unmarried woman could hold property,
she could make a contract,
she could engage independently in economic life.
But a married woman was subject to the legal doctrine of cover tour.
She was described in the law as a femme covert
and her rights was seriously curtailed by cover tour.
She could hold,
um,
no goods independently in marriage unless a separate trust had been erected for
her.
There was no community of goods.
Her husband got a life interest in any lands which he brought to the marriage.
All of the movable goods of the family were his
and her rights were limited to her dollar.
That was usually a third of the land and goods of the family,
which was reserved when her husband died to keep her in her widowhood and would
eventually revert to the main air of the family.
So that was the law as regards women and in particular their property rights.
And all of this was bolstered by widespread assumptions about the allegedly
inferior capacities of women,
not only in terms of physical strength but also in terms of at an allegedly
weakness of intellectual capacity and emotional stability.
The piece on the longer reading list by Crawford and Mendelssohn on women in
early modern England has an excellent lucid discussion of these issues in its
opening tractor,
especially the medical attitudes towards women at the time.
So as a result,
any failings which were observable in women were attributed not to,
they're on equal opportunities or they're restricted education,
but supposedly they're natural weaknesses.
And the fact that many men also shared these weaknesses was conveniently
overlooked.
Well,
the official view of the church on all of this was again read out every year in
another homily,
the homily on marriage,
the homily on marriage declared that and quoting the woman is a weak creature,
not endowed with the like strength and cost,
constancy of mind as men.
Therefore they be the sooner disquieted and they'd be the more prone to week
affections and dispositions of the mind more than men B and the homilist went on
that.
Therefore,
a woman must be spared and born with the rather in that she is the weaker
vessel,
the weaker vessel.
A phrase from the homily on marriage,
which was often repeated,
the same homily went on to advise that men and women should live in perpetual
friendship.
But it was one based of course upon the assumption of female acceptance of male
authority.
One of the great preachers of the late 16th century,
William Perkins,
a great puritan preacher who preached in the city of Cambridge,
uh,
set as follows,
concerning husbands and wives.
The good man or the master of the family is a person in whom restaurant,
the private and proper government of the whole household.
And he comes to it not by election but by the ordinance of God settled even in
the course of nature.
And he continued.
The good wife of the house is a person which yielded help and assistance in
government to the master of the family for he is,
as it were,
the prince and tiff ruler.
And she is his associate.
Well,
how far these prescriptions were actually observed in practice.
Um,
we'll see in the next lecture.
Uh,
and also if you wish to work on it.
There's an abundant literature on that issue,
but these were the prescriptive values of the time.
Now,
of course,
women,
whatever their formal subordination to their husbands and their fathers did of
course bear some authority in the Commonwealth alongside their husbands.
They bought authority over their children and over the servants and apprentices,
the young people who lived within their households.
Seventh,
we're generally young,
genuinely age between about 14 and the mid twenties they were generally hired on
annual contracts and they lived in the households of their masters and
mistresses and in return for their labor,
they were fed and clothed and give him lodging and a small wage,
which was very often paid only once a year.
Some seven stayed with particular households for years and might form quite a
close bond with their masters and mistresses,
but most moved on at the end of each year.
They would go to the hiring fair and be hired into a new household moving around
an area from village to village until they would eventually settle down and
marry in their mid to late twenties
in the towns,
the duties of sevens were largely domestic and servants were mostly women
leading some towns to have an unbalanced sex ratio in favor of women in the
countryside.
Both male and female servants worked on the farm,
engage in domestic tasks or in agricultural tasks.
They were known as servants in husbandry because they engaged in husbandry,
agricultural work,
but whatever the case servants were,
a very large and a very distinctive part of society,
a distinctive part of the labor force in particular in 16th century England,
it's been estimated that perhaps a quarter of the entire population lived in
other people's households as servants,
and it's been estimated that 60% of the population aged between 15 and 24 we're
living as servants at any one time.
So it was a distinctive element of the population and the distinctive phase of
the lifecycle.
For most young people
while they were living through that stage,
they lived under the authority of a master and the mistress in a household which
perhaps did a great deal to shape their social expectations,
particularly their expectations regarding authority.
Part of their socialization.
Apprentices were predominantly urban and they were usually male
young men in their late teens and early twenties.
For the most part,
one tends to think of apprentices as little boys sent out to learn a craft at
the age of seven or 10.
Um,
in fact,
they were more like modern students.
They were generally in their late teens and early twenties and they had been
bound by an indenture illegal indenture to a master to learn a trade over a
period of years.
Usually apprentices were migrants to the towns.
They'd come in to learn a trade.
We're bound lived in with their masters and like servants.
They were very numerous.
It's been estimated that in 1550 about 10% of the population of London were
apprentices.
They differed from servants in that they tended to stay with their master for
the whole period of their training,
which was usually a period of seven years.
They enjoyed a superior status because they had superior prospects in life.
One day they would be skilled journeymen and then perhaps mastercraftsman
themselves and they were aware of this distinction,
but in the meantime they too lived very much under the authority of their
masters.
So most of the young then lived in positions of subordination and they had
social identities which were merged with those of the adult householders under
whose authority they lived.
Um,
to give you one example of this,
I recently encountered,
I was looking at the deaths recorded in Paris,
registers a in a play gear in the early 17th century and it was striking that
servants were not recorded under their own names.
When servants had died of the plague and were buried,
they will put down in the parish register as Robert Foster's made or a man of
John Atkinson or terms like this,
the actual name of the servant not mentioned,
they just anonymous.
They're attributed to their master or the mistress.
When they were buried.
It's just a striking example of that kind of social,
um,
submergence within the identities of their superiors
and outside the household to the prevailing ideal of the age was what's been
called Geron Tow cratic.
That is to say the old should rule,
the young should serve and show respect.
The more or less of the time when they wrote about youth conventionally saw it
as a time of hope but also of danger.
The young were conventionally portrayed as being unusually subject to fits of
passion to rashness,
to volatility,
to intemperance and to sexual lasciviousness.
Um,
where they got this idea from one condo.
Imagine,
um,
wisdom and self control were regarded as coming only with age.
And accordingly there was a preference for agents seniority in all institutional
life.
Well,
one could say,
well that's just the same today,
but one important difference is that in the 16th and 17th centuries are far
larger proportion of the population were young.
The high birth rates of the time and the low life expectancy meant that the
population was far younger than is the case today.
Far fewer people lived through to their 50s and even fewer to their sixties when
they enjoyed these positions of authority.
So then the young lived also in a situation of subordination to adulthood came
only when they eventually married and achieved economic independence and had
households or workshops of their own.
Then young men were transformed into masters of families.
Young women were transformed into mistresses of families and their place in the
social order shifted upwards accordingly from that point on,
differences in their rank where paramount for men in the public domain of
society at large that within the house.
So differences of gender,
of course still held their place.
So to sum up,
this was a very highly structured and stratified society.
It was in egalitarian in its social ideals.
It was conceived of as a Commonwealth as an organic whole,
but one constituted of people whose opportunities and experiences we're very far
from uniform or equal.
And that structured in a quality was taken to be part of the natural order of
society.
Indeed,
it was taken to be ordained by God as we've seen.
It was a predominantly rural society in which most people gain their livings
from the land,
but in which a large minority,
we're also engaged in manufacturers and in trade.
It was a world in which most people still aspire to gain their living relatively
independently on the land or by practicing a trade,
but in which a large minority already dependent on selling their labor and
skills to others.
Throughout the whole structure,
the household was the principal place,
not only of residents,
but of economic production,
and it was the most immediate unit of authority under its master and mistress.
It's been said that to a very large extent,
social organization in this period was domestic organization focused on the
household,
be it the humble household or the great household of the aristocracy,
or indeed of the Monique himself.
So next time I'll take a closer look at how those thousands of households
functioned on the roles of men,
women,
and children within them,
on their priorities and strategies,
their basic values,
how they were formed,
and how so far as we can tell they lived.